does qualcomm want to be the brain of a
lot of autonomous vehicles in the future
of different you said brands like
mercedes-benz i don't know whatever just
whatever car you know cars have the the
sexy thing they do and then it defines
their brand and so so on and then
there's the brain that doesn't need to
have branding supposedly you know so
does qualcomm see that or will i be able
to buy a qualcomm car like literally no
you're not going to be able to buy a
qualcomm car but
we already we're already uh on our way
to become you know the brains of the car
the way you should think about qualcomm
automotive strategy is
the car companies
realize they need to become technology
companies you just look for example of
the market cap of some of the new uh uh
electrical uh comers and compare them
with
with the legacy uh car companies which
one is that i i heard of this well let's
just use like one of them lives in
austin let's say rivien right uh rivien
oh that one too yes you know the car
companies are not going away it's
actually a mistake not to bet in the car
companies huh
the core companies need a technology
partner
they will provide
the digital chassis for them and that's
what we're doing so if you look at
qualcomm we talk about a snapdragon
digital chassis so
we
want to be the preferred technology
partner of
the car companies and i think it's
working strategy is working right now so
basically helping companies the car
companies accelerate into this
into becoming technology companies
connecting the car to the cloud
redesigned the interior of the digital
cockpit experience and provide the
computation and sensor capabilities for
autonomy and assisted driving
you